coach good morning how do you feel this
morning good morning Dan feeling good I
got up and got my workout in and the
necessity to be productive is something
that that this family that I'm part of
the smiles group it kind of requires of
you how were you told you were fired
face to face
Joel ever said worth big change and and
and I'm for the Tigers and anything that
that they see that it makes the Tigers
better than I'm formed and I accepted
you know that that at out come in and
support and will support that decision
and these Tigers would go forward
did you try to fight it I and it was
beyond fighting it the the enjoyment of
being here the enjoyment of community
the experiences that my family's had
it's too important to me to fight over I
mean it's it's a it's a its history it's
what we are and if if they see that a
change makes the Tigers better than I am
perform did you realize it was this
tenuous that you know one second if you
could beat Auburn then all of a sudden
you're still employed I mean what was it
was it coming down to something as my
new does that well I I want you to know
something
the how that game is was the Tigers
fighting forever for their breath and in
doing everything that they could maybe
there's a way that the coach could have
gotten a second more I would I would I
would argue that that I made those those
moves but I won second at no it's it's
certainly a decision that was made more
appropriately over more than a second it
felt like had been hanging there even
last year I mean even previous years
would you say that it was sort of an
undercurrent there that whether you felt
it or not that it was still kind of
lingering yeah if if it was there i I
went beyond it I enjoyed going into my
room I enjoyed seeing the young men that
I recruited and coached I was fortunate
to be with a great coaching staff and
guys that were committed to great game
playing so I'm working hard and so I if
there was an undercurrent it did not
exist in that building in that building
it was about football and football
opinion and best way to win and that's
all it was and it was a cultural kind of
divide if you will what goes on outside
that building is just didn't just didn't
matter
he's Les Miles former LSU head coach
joining us you get a chance to talk to
your players I did and I appreciate it
Oliva allowing me to do that and I
recognize you know in those decisions so
many times you can see where it's not
necessarily that the the ex head coach
you know says goodbye and but they gave
me an opportunity and I took advantage
of it and it did not stay long but wish
them well they deserve the best and I
think I think the new like I think
editor on to a great job form and and I
then I exited as fast as I could
how tough is this jobless I think it's a
blast i I think coaching football in
being with young players and and
developing them and and having the few
that say thanks taking the team into an
opponent Stadium and and coming out with
victory I think the if you're a
competitive man if you enjoy competition
I think I don't think it's jobs hard I
think it's a joy
do you do anything differently do you
beat yourself up a little bit
looking back I always review everything
and in certain certain things we can be
better and I you know I think I gave us
a chance to win the game and I you know
to defend myself that's what I did
but yeah I've done better you betcha I
think every time that I play every time
they take a team to the field like I
review the things that have happened if
there's ways that I can be better
i person's we could have had that we
could call to place in low and but the
problem of calling to place in a rose
you don't know exactly what the history
at the last play was in other words what
the coverage was what how did they
decide to play you how aggressively and
you want to have a good call but of
course you want to have you know the
game so I say and I think there's
there's ways to be better you want to
coach again soon I you know I don't golf
I play no tennis I enjoy shooting the
gun I don't necessarily like the pointed
animals I play cards I don't not very
well but what I have done for probably
12 to 14 hours a day for the last number
of years just coach football so I I
would have a difficult time not being
involved in the game and not being a
coach it's it's scary to think about not
coaching no I don't think I think I know
the the not coaching I I think there's
always a Plan C out there and and I have
to have a daughter and a son in college
one in Texas and and I want UNC and I
could certainly go find those games on
the weekend because football is going to
be a part and
I have a young son who's going to be a a
could be committed currently to a Big
Ten Conference team and very quality one
and like I said I think I could find
something to do but I enjoy football and
I I can't imagine that that I won't be
involved in some way what would you tell
your successor how fortunate you are to
coach the LSU Tigers take them to the
field and to walk into the home and
represent them and recruit and expect
the best because that's who they're your
coaching and that's who you represent if
you lie yourself feel sorry for yourself
at any point here last 24 hours
are you kidding me I have had a great
run at LSU and I enjoyed myself the
entire time and they decided your Hill
the first game we played at Arizona
State
we Jacob Hester and Craig stouts scored
a blocked a field goal and scored and
and they punted this court and in my
first game I came from behind and I
think with points scored 14 points in a
minute and a half and came from behind
to beat a very quality or so to say
state team there and to think that that
you can't that you're you're going to
live your life and in play in that style
of game you know weekend after weekend
to me that is that I don't see any other
way what are you going to do this
Saturday that's going to be a tough one
because you know if if I can find you
and if I can find the ticket and I think
they play a four state I think I mean
see if my son can arrange a ticket or I
might I tell you one thing I'm rootin
for the LSU Tigers we'll be rooting for
the Tar Heels I'm goin for the Cowboys
and I'm rootin for Michigan and that's
and then when Ben ends up at the school
that he's committed to then I'm the look
for them so it's uh it's just a way this
a good luck in the future of their coach
Thanks
we appreciate you joining us and you
know you're handling a lot better than I
would but you know I'd be going kicking
and screaming but as you said you got an
opportunity to do something great won a
national title there and there'll be
something down the road but thank you
for joining us Dan I appreciate the call
thank you sorry that's Les Miles former
LSU head coach you can't talk yourself
back into a job and it felt like this
was they were looking for a moment the
tipping point they got it successful
successful early winning that national
title back in oh seven but I think
people always looked at quarterbacking
play they were never a pass happy team
and it feels like college football has
evolved into that that you got to have
that great quarterback in there and they
hadn't done that and with all these
players that go to the NFL we'd always
look and say shouldn't they be better at
LSU yeah boy do you guys think you could
do that 18 hours after being fired
publicly fired you know go on a national
radio show with that type of positivity
and does that also tell you what he must
be like in a living room when he's
recruiting it says a lot about his
personality whether he's
compartmentalized it or maybe he's
fooling himself in how he feels today
but he's saying the right things and
he's also looking at that next job how
he handles himself with this with
dignity with class and bowing out there
I understand it good job Fritzi tracking
down coach miles there I will take a
break we'll come back more of your phone
calls it's 9th
Kien after they are by the way coach
miles brought to you by continental
coaches tires man they Coaches Corner
Continental Tire coaches contract right
yeah man just rolled right off my tongue
maybe we could send coach some tires
they're the cheer-mom he's driving out
of town get coach tires not tiger not
Tigers no tire tires the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]